[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm rent and I'm link joining us this
week at the roundtable of dim lighting
are lizzy and ellie members of the
mythical crew who I'm sure you know
because they appear in lots of good
mythical morning more videos on the
vistas mythical channel they do they are
writers and segment producers of good
mythical morning and they're just
generally good people to hang out real
good and convert indecent about things
are so good and decent and they also
they they're really into celebrity
celebrity conspiracy theories when we
did the episode of GMM about celebrity
conspiracy theories yeah like Taylor
Swift being the devil they were all
about that they did the research for the
anok worshiper and they they were like
cuz this is like a hobby of ours we're
really into it Beyonce faking her
pregnancy and so we were like well you
guys should just come on a near biscuit
and then try to convince us of some yeah
if you're so into it let's talk it out
so that's what happens yes so um that it
remains to be seen whether or not we
will be convinced but you're gonna have
to stick around to find out um another
piece of business we want to do is thank
you guys for all of your support with
our in our decision to release what we
were calling the the lost or the shelved
episode last week where we had some
technical issues and then we didn't know
if we're going to release it then we did
and we called it let's get personal
because we got personal in a number of
ways talking about the the proctology
visits and then Lily's back situation
and gearing up for surgery which hasn't
happened yet that's going to be towards
the beginning of May when that happens
but you guys have just been
overwhelmingly positive and saying
thanks for sharing you know for being
vulnerable about all of those things and
so we appreciate the feedback that you
guys are that you guys are into it
you know I want to pass on Lily and the
rest of my families thanks to you guys
for all your thoughts and prayers and
support that you've given through your
tweets and your comments we've seen
those and we appreciate it and I will
give you an update you know on the back
side of the surgery no pun intended
and speaking of back side you know I
think we did get a lot of positive
feedback about us talking about
proctology so we should just continue
that trip we should just keep talking
about you know but doctor because you've
got a special trip that you're preparing
for tomorrow
that's right which is which is related
to the the initial trip right I don't
remember how much I connected it to but
he said you should get just to be safe
because you're of age the doctor said my
daughter didn't say this he said you
should get a colonoscopy because you
know there's a history of like colon
colon issues in your family and my
family and then if there's well let's
just be real if there's some if there's
ever any scenario of like bleeding in
the stool or in that area well they want
to make sure it's not coming from
something up in there right and I said
well and then they're saying that there
is there are some studies that are
saying screen earlier screen earlier
than 40 years old yeah which would be
now yeah so I'm like well you're okay
I'm I'm just gonna do this I mean how
bad can it be
and I can say well I haven't done it yet
I'm doing it tomorrow which means that
you but today has been bad you haven't
eaten anything and you've been drinking
a lot of water and then you drank some
sort of substance this is 6 a.m. in the
morning so which meant I couldn't eat
when I woke up this morning I couldn't
eat breakfast and I had to be on like a
liquid diet I had to be fasting from
solids and anything that you can't shine
a light through so I could have like a
chicken I could shine a light through
chicken a chicken boy yeah real like it
you get a strong enough laser I can sit
through a rib
like a 5,000 lumen boom headling that is
not a good measure because there's so
many ways around that with lasers and
did you ask him about lasers I didn't it
was a it was a it was a handout I can't
talk to you mean China like a normal
light through and light comes out the
other side got to be clear so for
breakfast I didn't I didn't have my
award-winning smoothie featured in the
mythical monthly newsletter what award
did it win links awesome smoothie recipe
award that I gave warded but I mean to
yourself I really miss that right off
the bat I had I can drink coffee but
black you don't realize how much a man
of routine he is and I love the taste of
it it's so good not getting not getting
that smoothie that you've set in motion
now my day was started off on the wrong
foot when I could I mean if I couldn't
have had my coffee I would not be here
now you wouldn't you couldn't have been
around me but see but here's a bone
broth for breakfast and and for lunch
and dinner jello is something I had
yellow jello yeah which is lemon and I
hated that for like a brunch and then
for lunch I had chicken broth and then
no I had beef broth and then in the
afternoon I had another chicken broth
which was nasty and then at 6:00 p.m. I
had to drink I had to start going
full-fledged cleanse and they gave me
this special cup and it they put some
sort of like very special like cherry
flavored concoction in there and I had
to drink that whole thing and then drink
two more things of water that sets
everything in motion because they want
to go in there they want to be and want
to be clean as a whistle in there they
want to see nothing but the inside of
your body not what's inside your body
because let's be clear they're gonna oh
my gosh I'm holding it back right now no
yep okay I'm holding back what diarrhea
like a cleansing fountain a man of hell
I'm glad I'm here for this oh man it's
been a tough day because of a sake
put a camera up your butt in the morning
I have to drink another one of these and
then I have to show up it I have to get
up it before six o'clock I have to drink
another one of these regimens that's
gonna clean me out even more yes and
then I'm gonna get go there at 9 a.m.
and they're gonna run a camera they're
gonna put me in a twilight State and
we're gonna broadcast this live I'm
gonna Sparkle I casted life we're not
but we're not they're gonna put me in a
twilight State which I guess is like
when you have your wisdom teeth removed
they're gonna put a camera up my ass or
the net more than that I mean I didn't
have anything but wisdom teeth it's at
local anesthesia this is like you're
gonna affect your mind well let they
give you like the funny gas yeah so they
put some people under more I think yeah
this is more than that they fill my
whole cruel learning up with what I
water I'm not water fill your whole my
whole colon up with air and then they
run a camera up in there and they look
at the whole thing to see if there's
even gonna be great any polyps or cancer
or
conditions or whatever I don't know I
don't expect him to find anything I'm
really I'm rather confident that
everything's gonna but that's why you're
doing it I don't know I'm not nervous at
all but I do like to know and I kind of
like the experience well what no I don't
I like to have experiences and this but
I but I don't I I haven't enjoyed myself
I've had a miserable time I kind of like
the experience I feel like I've made
made everyone around me miserable and
I'm sorry but let me let me just say
because what you've experienced today is
something that people go to on retreats
to experience like the idea of fasting
you've just joined the ranks of the
great gurus and leaders of the history
like you make a plane in the whole time
about how hard it is but like that's the
whole point I've been complaining the
whole time embracing that the obstacles
right no what if they have to run I
might have to run to the restroom you
can hold it man that week it was getting
just a couple more minutes okay
yeah now because man if the contractions
start coming more frequently I'm gonna
have to deliver it's not a baby
it's not a baby
its water bagel and right into the
toilet it's based on what happened of
just a few minutes ago it was just a
liquid bit okay but listen what I'm
saying is this is the kind of thing that
people especially in this town do on a
regular basis to get cleansed people pay
lots of money to be cleansed and you're
fasting and cleansing and this is
something that I actually I had to eat
something on the show today I in and so
you having to getting to do this I was
kind of envious of you as I'd like to be
fasting with link today but headache and
I was very grumpy I don't know if you
noticed right but if you do enough times
and you get over that and then you begin
to embrace it it becomes like a way of
life there's people who swear by it then
you're just you just open the door to
something that could be it could be
incredible man you're like yeah I I feel
like I've been awakened to my dependence
on food it's exactly that's the first
step it's disturbing it just opened the
door to the first step man feels so weak
man don't exactly only thinks strong
right now is my sphincter and if it
wasn't for that there'd be quite a mess
on the floor you're being exposed you're
gonna be really exposed tomorrow but I
won't but it's like you're being exposed
to this thing that's just its refining
who you are this is an experience that
you don't focus on the food that you're
not eating focus on the fact that you're
doing something that other people want
don't focus on what you want focus on
what you're getting that other people
want oh yeah well that's what I said I
like to have an experience I don't know
if I'm gonna like the experience but now
you're saying like the experience and
hopefully you'll be a little wacky when
you come out of there and we'll get some
good video footage of you telling about
yourself yeah either you'll pick me up
or I'll get a deal to pick me up and
show video something either way it'll be
fun out of here okay that's that's the
proper term but don't do that before we
take a short break to let everybody know
that we're selling beauty products
[Laughter]
who else do you know that goes from
talking about a colonoscopy and and
creating a butt fountain to selling hair
product in lip balm and beard oil now
you may know you know we partner with
Bearden lady on all these products and
they have been available for sale on
Amazon this year and now they are
available at retina or so you can still
get them on Amazon but you can also get
them at our store lots of you who use
these things use the beard oil or the
lip balm or the pomade swear by it and
then put your reviews and your comments
and your pictures all social media we
see you we hear you when you talk about
I mean I had there's a guy the other day
who posted a picture of like ten bottles
of my beard oil that he's gone through
10 bottles he's my god no but he loves
it he loves the smell of it and he's got
a big beard apparently likes to keep it
oiled up like a fine-tuned machine I
like to all my lips with peculiarly
perfect peanut butter peppermint lip
balm and I use this pomade every day man
absolutely
add a little blow dry into the mix
afterward if you want to give a little
ya completed look or you can just walk
out with the wetness and let it dry walk
out with the wetness we can walk out
with a wetness your buddies up yeah yeah
so let's uh let's get on to the biscuit
with Lizzie and Ellie you can take a
just a short bathroom break if you want
to because we've already recorded it
enjoy
[Music]
all right here you are and we're gonna
we're gonna talk conspiracy theories
celebrity conspiracy theories yes okay
but first before we get into that we owe
it to the people to the ear biscuit ears
to give them an update on your
relationship that you've started with a
guy from bubble that we talked about in
the episode how Millennials date yeah we
we we sparked this relationship back up
and I've been saving saving my questions
about this guy until right now because
we told you to say something I can't
remember we told you to say what did you
say I said exactly what you told me to
say I said sorry I'm terrible about
checking this app how's the meal prep
going he said Lowell it didn't last the
whole week I ate them faster than
anticipated I said that's exactly what
happened to me when I tried to do it
also cooking things and thinking I'll
have leftovers is a joke he said very
true and that was the end of our
relationship well that was the end of
the cover because you didn't pick it
back up well let it go this he said very
true which was it wasn't he wasn't
exactly continuing the conversation very
true and by the way would you like to
date you know or very true with a
question mark yeah you know you yeah I
like to end all conversations with that
I want to continue with question marks
so what's what's your objective here I
mean how's this gonna work
what do you want are you trying to
convince us of something yeah we just
want to open your eyes the real truth
which I mean if as you've probably
guessed things are not quite as they
seem especially amongst famous people so
our goal is definitely to we just want
to show you these conspiracy theories
cover the real factual evidence that's
real a nice cool evidence that it's real
you're already hedged it's real also I'd
just like to say that for me personally
this is very much a play to get myself a
seat at the Illuminati table so they're
listening there's a
they're always listen yeah there's a
table there's a round tables don't Vinci
Code they don't want to be called out
though okay no I haven't well okay I
understand that but like how am I gonna
get into the Eyes Wide Shut party if I
don't ask for an invite I don't think
they're gonna approach me so yeah this
is my ask with Ellie yeah I would like
to be there too is this is this DaVinci
Code or Eyes Wide Shut what movie are we
talking about everything Vanilla Sky
probably not there's Illuminati
references in paul blart mall cop
[Laughter]
started on katy perry that's a whole
episode so we're not talking about Katy
Perry now how is this working are you
guys do you are you combatants in this
do you each have no I think did you
bring in yeah we have something to share
with you guys and then I don't actually
know what she has I know I have and I'm
unprepared to be open-minded to what she
brings to the smaller round table which
is what like as an overview what do you
have well yeah I've heard of him he's a
good-looking guy
yeah recognize that it's cuz he's an
immortal being who's been with us
through almost every century in time and
I'm ready to prove that to you tonight
okay and Lizzie what are you what are
you proving okay mine is not about
immortal beings mine is about very
mortal beings and one in particular
which is Lindsay Lohan's identical twin
have I hooked you hmm I hooked you
remember The Parent Trap
that wasn't green-screen oh well because
she played two different people in it no
she didn't rat that was her identical
twin which I will get into a commentary
there was twins in that movie right but
there is but there's been a cover-up of
the twin and a cover-up of Kiana's
immortality yeah it's kind of doing most
of the work himself he's very he's very
thorough though okay so where we're
going first yeah let's get into the
evidence who we gonna hear from I guess
I'll I'll start
so obviously 1998 we all remember the
Parent Trap the remake of the classic
1950s or 60s movie one of those doesn't
matter this is the new one
it started Lindsay Lohan it was her big
break she got a lot of success out of
this and everybody was saying oh how
amazing that this you know 11 12 year
old played two characters so
convincingly it was incredible and after
that she she was in Herbie the lovebug
well Mean Girls first right which was
also a remake of a Disney movie yeah if
we're going off of this timeline oh the
twin died yeah oh I just spoiled
something for you guys I'm sorry her
twins dead so here's what happened well
hence the cover oh that's convenient
yeah so they're murdering she has a twin
named Kelsey there could be Kelsey Lohan
Kelsey Lowe like to introduce you guys
to Kelsey Lohan after they finished
filming The Parent Trap these two
incredible twins that Disney had located
there was a horrible car crash in which
Kelsey was tragically lost who however
Disney decided that they did not want to
promote a movie where a little girl had
just died obviously I don't never work
right clearly the way to still make
money off of this even more money is to
say that it was all Lindsay and that she
was so impressive that she played both
parts so that's theory number one buzz
worthy and not sad it's it's inspiring
can I ask one question I'm sure you'll
get into this but does that mean that if
you watch because typically when there's
one person playing two roles in a movie
you can kind of tell that they're like
cheated like oh yeah they don't really
cross it they don't cross each other and
is that kind of stuff but those effects
are really expensive I mean in his
Disney we're talking about they got
money but is it is it very clear that
there's there's lots of things that
would have been very expensive effects
that they could have avoided well
interesting you should bring that up
because some people actually do point to
the accuracy of the green-screen in that
movie as being impressive because it was
in 1998 that it came out which means it
was shot I believe principle shooting
began in 1997 and people say that they
didn't have green screen that good
because they actually do
cross paths quite a bit in the movie I
would like you to take a look at this
image here where they are touching each
other found it creepy like friends is
this a still from a video or is this
just a photo this is a production still
supposedly from this movie now there are
people that say that these are not
identical twins that it's not the same
person they note slight differences in
the nose as well as in the teeth it's
like a Rorschach test and I do start to
see differences like after images well
eventual test there's a there's a like a
freckle on this left cheek I think
that's our printer one hair is you need
to be like yeah that's a freckle and
then that's which one's Lizzie you think
it's just a printer which one is Lindsey
well the one on the right the the left
of the picture has a little gum disease
starting that's not Lindsey you see that
little gum disease starting mm-hmm you
don't see that on this one so the other
theory is that dead Quinn had gum
disease yeah well that's why they got
rid of her which brings me to the second
theory which is that Disney had hit
taken out on Gossage oh wow what is
Disney what did he have to gain from
killing a child guys Gration want to pay
two of them they don't have that kind of
money they had to just pay one they were
like pick the better one and we'll just
promote that one and then we'll off the
other one and it's fine
yeah because Lou is a financial
motivation that is the theory yeah and
Lindsay's parents are just gonna be like
yeah just I'll just well once one of my
kids is dead I'll just you can just pay
for the one that's still living yeah her
dad Michael Lohan absolutely
he's not above that guy what does he
have convinced Michael on the record I
think if we met Michael in a bar or
restaurant establishment he would
probably tell us all about this that's
my guess
yeah he's there a mess I mean that
that's the other thing is like the
family fell apart so much in that
Lindsay Lohan fell apart so much and the
theories that it was like survivor's
guilt and also that she took credit for
her sister's role and that's what the
deterioration came from well I mean and
also there's the theory that you know
Disney paid off the family because you
would the question I have in my head is
what you asked which is like what
parents would even if the kid died
accidentally in a car accident what
parents would then agree to cover this
up but then you're like michael and dina
Lohan those are the parents that would
agree in order to get more money
yeah but then Disney wanted to pay less
money so then that doesn't add up those
are two separate theories so if you're
going the more like sort of violent
Disney put a hit out on this 11 year old
girl theory then yes that's it I don't
subscribe to that one
I didn't mean either I subscribed to the
that Kelsey was tragically lost and
Disney made the best of a bad situation
they didn't want to make the movie the
promotion of the movie and releasing the
movie just be surrounded by this yeah
tragedy and you can have this this
photoshopped image that's passing as a
production photo back thank you that is
two different people and not at all
photoshopped okay but that's fine well
it's funny you should mention the
Photoshop as well because only about two
years ago the girl who claimed to be
Lindsay Lohan's body double during the
movie came forward yeah her name is Erin
Mackie and also interesting that she
didn't come forward with this until 2015
which is when these rumors started to
circulate on the Internet
what body double and what did she say
you tell my stand-in or someone who like
she acted against because they had to
she had to play both roles because she
released pictures that she says are from
the set however people think that the
lighting looks very different on her vs.
on everyone else so she you think that
this this body double
photoshopped herself into these Disney
photoshopped her into those photos
because people started
realize what they had done yeah that
can't get out you know no okay so this
is the little girl who played that
played the twin yes also she is seven
years older than Lindsay Lohan so
they're claiming that she is the same
age well that she's seven years older
than Lindsay Lohan in those pictures
which that does not make any sense to me
no no that's what the actual like real
world timeline is supposed to be yes
seven years older yes how old was
Lindsay in this picture she's like 11 so
this girl is 18 allegedly yeah okay so
you're telling me that right now this
little girl who what was her name
Erin Maki here we can wait Erin Maki if
you look Erin Maki up on wiki yeah she's
right now she's gonna be seven years
older than Lindsay Lohan that's what the
Seventeen magazine article told me I
mean my highly-trained be able to afford
a one-bedroom in Manhattan where did you
get them is that Dennis Quaid yeah
Dennis Quaid and Natasha Richardson
Hillary Rodham Clinton no it doesn't
like he doesn't especially in this one
it's poor Natasha Richardson who really
did meet an untimely end
oh she did oh yeah that's that I liked
her we see this story's already said why
you got to add another dead girl to it I
didn't add it Disney did so okay but
free look that up you supposed to be
seven years difference yeah if they're
claiming that then what oh wait I'm
telling you I read a Seventeen magazine
thing where they were like she is seven
years older than Lindsay seventeen all
right don't always gotta cross checked
out Seventeen magazine
you know Seventeen magazine that's
definitely on me but yeah I still think
those pictures look doctored I'll stand
by that I don't look look at her I don't
why would you choose this picture it's a
horrible picture that one is interesting
unless you had to choose a picture where
you were the right size and height in
order to photoshop it in with Lindsay
Lohan I'm not sure if Dennis Quaid was
actually there
no head is way too large as it had
really that big yes Dennis Quaid has a
very large head the Quaid boys have big
heads which a lot of actors do wait is
Randy Quaid his brother is that right
yeah well because lead is involved in
this so you know there's no weird going
on yeah why do you think he's so
obsessed with the star whackers you know
their assassin group she is so right a
listers and he's in hiding where they'd
told Dennis Quaid or Dennis Quaid saw it
happen and so that's obvious right
Rennie looks good these days that's
insight you just gave insight into how
these conspiracy theories happen yeah
it's just I'm gonna you just added a
little something a little something with
the Randy Quaid thing like you just you
brought him into the mix like you
literally put him at the scene of this
new cast aspersion yes look at your new
cast aspersion yeah yeah but in a
factual and hopeful way in a hopeful way
[Laughter]
if we want to go away from facts because
you seem to have a problem with those I
think what sold me on this theory when I
was thinking about it is that I remember
watching The Parent Trap yeah
fundamentally being blown away yes by
how good it is and I've never felt that
way about one with like like you ever
seen an Adam Sandler movie or any Murphy
Perry movie well if it crosses it's
green yeah that's true but if it doesn't
then it's split-screen but I mean there
are it is exceptionally good if it's not
if it's one person it's very good it's
amazing I remember like I definitely
thought they were two girls when I was
little cuz I was I was young when this
came out and and it broke my heart that
it was just one girl cuz I thought they
were like the cool sisters ever and they
weren't cuz they were sisters well I
remember when I found out that the the
little girl on Full House was actually
two girls and I felt ripped off yeah
yeah don't you think if they needed two
girls on full house they would need two
girls for something as in
as The Parent Trap yeah hello well and
especially to play right well I mean
think about it you've got two girls
playing one person it's four times it's
hard for one person to play two people
that's the math that's yeah actor math
it is the math because if you got two
people playing half a role and then
you've got one person playing two roles
yeah what are the two times one half is
two maybe Lindsay that is the math and
you know in quadruplets I don't mean to
make this about us but whenever we were
writing like the the doppelganger part a
buddy system and we knew we were gonna
have to like do a bunch of split-screen
acting against ourselves and like we had
a couple of green screen shots we and
they're very obvious we were like you're
like we have to we got to minimize this
because we know it's not gonna be fun to
act against nobody
and also Disney wasn't paying for it
though I mean 1997 though it were the 20
years ago but not late 90s Disney they
okay what's the budget for the Parent
Trap that is not information that I have
but I do have a computer in front of me
they've locked it up it wouldn't no one
can access oh I can't reach the budget
for 1998 is the one we're looking for
fifteen point five million that is not
that much money that's really low that's
really low I just actually just really
helped your theory a lot cuz it was like
25 30 million you know Dennis Quaid yeah
he was the entire budget he's taking
seven down you know I mean your green
screen line item is uh is nil it is
awfully suspicious and also there's a
name for this twin like I could not
figure out where the name came from but
Calais I can't tell if somebody just
decided that this girl was named Kelsey
Lohan or or if your theory about Michael
Lohan is accurate and that he was like
three deep at a bar and told somebody
about this story which that's my bet I
think Michael Lohan spilled the beans
okay you know what else you got how do
does this go is there just is there
another you know well what do you call
it when something seals the deal is
there a is there a gun is there a body
you're not convinced yeah where's the
where's the body
no you know what that's uh that's it
wait I do have one more useful detail
which this is an important one a comment
or I'm one of our this is mythical
videos here we go
recently just theorized that I have a
twin named Amber who only steps in to do
nasty food challenges that I don't want
to do and I would like to take this
moment right now to confirm that that is
true and it's really useful to have a
twin that I don't have to pay or let out
of the closet except for when I don't
want to do a food video you keep her in
a closet
yeah she also get her hair cut she had
to and you didn't tell us about her no I
don't want you to pay her that's great
yeah so I saved you the issue that
Disney had right you don't have to
choose to kill one of us now that we
know well you're what you're really
saying is that you parent trapped us
yeah isn't that the plot of parent
trapped is that they only have one kid
bring up we brought you back together
it's actually a really messed up movie
when you think about it the parents got
divorced and then they're like well I
want to live in London and he's like I
want to live in Napa and they're like
let's just split up the kids and lie to
them and tell them they're only children
and they're like okay and then they
split up and then that's what happens
that's what happens and then they go to
summer camp meet at summer camp yeah and
then also inexplicable why they don't
realize they're twins immediately it's
look at each other and they go whoa we
look alike
Haylee meal meals Hayley Mills there was
the original one yeah and she didn't
have a twin no they did the remake that
movie you like it's rough it looks like
they're just shooting her in separate
rooms together so if Disney is twisted
enough to remake such a twisted plot
line
what kind of parents do that live their
children parents but then they brought
him spoiler alert they brought him back
together you both version which is also
messed up to make children of divorce
hope for their parents getting back
together it's like that's not gonna
happen and probably shouldn't happen if
they're divorced but yeah but just
divorce parents are hopeful oh yeah for
multiple generations because of the two
versions of the movie thanks to Disney
thanks Disney if they're that ruthless
you're telling me they could probably
offer a child in order to save a little
money to put in towards a green screen
budget of the next Parent Trap three
yeah I don't believe that they would
kill a kid no but I don't know I think
but I think that if it happened and she
hadn't broken out yet yeah they might
they might cover it up that's the thing
she's completely unknown but I think
there would be lots of lots of pictures
of them together as kids that we will be
fine well before the digital age how
hard is it to get rid of those it's not
like now fire fireplace yeah just throw
those Polaroids right in the fire yeah
there's no there's no digital legacy
there's no Facebook or anything of these
kids so if if all you have or what's the
other one
what's just custom since they weren't
close press is a good one the Sprouse
boys express twins okay
all right I'd say that I'd say it's it's
well anything's plausible lots of it's
not impossible but it's not probable all
right Seventeen magazine really messed
me up let's see what Ellie's got Ellie
what you got alright Keanu Reeves is an
immortal being okay this is distortion
of plausible you're looking well you
she's grabbing something he a nose under
the face she's grabbing some prints this
is all the evidence you should need and
if that if that doesn't convince you
enough I have lots of things to go in
1994 to 2008 the man does not age so my
question is how and here is why he is
immortal well his eyes
I just got smaller in 2008 that's the
one thing that happened okay you didn't
really get any wrinkles his jawline
stayed pretty much the same you have a
beard and John wick because how does a
man with that pattern of facial hair
actually pull off a beard it's a good
beard dude I think if he has some elixir
in his bloodstream mmm or just gross I
think I think his beard is supplemented
supplemented with makeup I actually have
a point about that okay all right okay
all right so yeah he you know 14 14
years later yeah it doesn't look like 14
years of age yeah any man should be
jealous of that type of aging so if that
doesn't convince you alone and I
understand your first question when
you're told that Keanu Reeves might be
immortal is why are we just seeing him
now you know he's he's lived for however
many eons and we're just hearing about
him now well spoiler alert he's popped
up through history other times and there
is a whole website dedicated to proving
this called Keanu Musa mortal calm well
that's a convenient name yeah I mean
they've got the domain handle and they
did it right what if they had to buy
that off of some dude who was like
squatting on it ya know one of these
days or Kioto probably himself yeah he's
making them all he's been very careful
but he's definitely slipped up in the
past I actually think he has fun with it
so the first time Keano has popped up
and I think this is around the time he
was born and became immortal is with the
great Emperor Charlemagne I don't know
if you're aware of Charlemagne Magna
Carta I actually don't know what what
years are we talking we're talking about
uh 882 814 AD so he's most notable as an
emperor of the Holy Roman Empire and he
he pursued an aggressive campaign to
protect the papacy and helped push the
spread of Christianity throughout the
Roman Empire and modern-day Europe to
talk about ours I know it doesn't sound
like he honors Charlemagne
Charlamagne it's also keanu what I
thought he's gonna be like an assistant
you're telling me Charlemagne is kion oh
yes I am okay you got pictures of
Charlemagne yeah they didn't have yeah
but when you're a famous Holy Roman
Emperor
you have portraits so check this out
don't look at the bottom one yeah was he
English was he French
he was like Italian sort of Turkish
really he went through I'm not an expert
on trial main I am an expert on how he
is similar to well Charlemagne's beard
here is a lot more than Keanu you see
how
beardy he can get yes the same beard
Shape I mean it really is it really is
even and I couldn't find a picture of
candy with a crown but I feel like I
hold it on their head similar look at
the patch on each side of his little his
soul patch
you got the negative beard there around
the soul patch is the same thing yeah so
you can't hang a whole theory on that
guy's well I have what what other
evidence about Charlemagne here's the
thing
you may think no we can't be Charlemagne
because Charlemagne caused so much
bloodshed with like forcefully making
people be Christians and stuff but I
feel like if you work yeonu and you were
just turned or more at all I feel like
you'd have a lot of angst and you just
kind of go wild and you'd want to like
go go hard as an immortal being like you
can't die why not do all these things so
hard or go home
the Holy Roman Emperor and he did all
this stuff and I think that also
explains why he chilled out later in his
later centuries that's why it ain't
Point Break this is your only evidence
for him being Charlotte man is that he
cut he has to negative beard spaces they
match though I'm looking at the nose is
pretty similar I'll give you that I'm
asking is that it for Charlotte no it's
not I know I just want to make one point
though I I did jump ahead a tiny bit and
I will say that the negative space on
the right side of Keanu's chin does
appear to match the same on
Charlemagne's I'm just saying yeah the
soul patch is slight
the off-center look at the one look at
the next picture yeah yeah a beard or
lack of beard is not a fingerprint but
have you ever stuck your beard in ink at
the police station
okay no no but I will now
[ __ ] you you get arrested for something
you're like insisting to put your beard
no no no that means take my beer didn't
it's more reliable this is the only
silver lining I have for being arrested
is I get to finally do this thing that I
talked about on a podcast where I was
being convinced that Keanu Reeves is
Charlemagne when did his head the weight
Charlemont died is the most interesting
the Charlemont I like these many
Charlemont
so he felt it with pleurisy which is an
inflammation in the chest cavity which
is very uncommon in that time it's weird
not to die with like weird skin rashes
and stuffs and like no one he didn't
look like he was dying from the outside
and then one day he was just like oh my
son you're gonna be the Emperor I'm
gonna go die now and literally laid down
in a bed and was like give me on my last
rites and then he died and it's like
literally being like I'm really dying
okay I'm dead now and like closed his
eyes and then he was entombed
above-ground and some guy some emperor
otto from the count of the palace of
Aachen went to go visit him and it said
that they claimed Charlemagne was seated
upon a throne wearing a crown and
holding a scepter and his flesh was
almost entirely incorrupt because it
wasn't corrupt because he wasn't dead he
was just a press wasn't talking make
anything up back then no no he was just
sitting
he was just sitting I mean like you know
in like Twilight the really old Italian
vampires yeah like really slow and like
don't do anything because they're so
bored because they've been immortal for
so long yes that's what I'm imagining
you run out of zest for life when it
doesn't end yeah so he had a low point
there he died he was Emperor he thought
he'd done it on a low point to set to
sitting there in a tomb on earth or
haven't you seen the sad Keanu meme
that's probably what he was doing he
just takes breaks where he sits on park
benches or in tombs
and is sad for a little bit and then he
gets back in the court in the game
though like what did we need he bounced
back history okay he that he was
depressed he was sad he was over being
immortal he pops back up in the 19th
century as Paul Mooney that was quite a
break though I gotta say that was quite
a break a little bit complicated theory
that he's also Hamlet but we don't have
to go and yeah he's based off this guy
named Hamlet who was my new Danish
Prince yeah basically he was a
scandinavian prince who went through the
exact same travails and he didn't like
he died mysteriously also and there's a
photo evidence that they kind of locks
but back to the artist he is on this is
not the artist is an mou and et moaning
he was a actor in France in the 19th
century kind of working on his act in
child and that's him right there and
don't they look the same
okay so different beard than Charlemagne
wax that's all well it doesn't connect
he has so Pat has a soul patch of it
maybe maybe that's a style choice it
could be a style choice definitely shave
done but it kind of grows in the same
sort of plume you know but you're
telling me that Keanu Reeves had over
150 years or so to work on his acting
and he's as good as he is now yes he's
amazing what are you talking about an
acting have you ever seen Point Break
matrix peed John Billington yeah I've
seen them all they're always great
they're all great movies I see you
matrix not because of Keanu scenes Wow
okay this is a fundamental disagreement
and it is subjective and I do only care
about facts I care about opinions and I
love Keanu Reeves no I think oh wait he
was in that Shakespeare movie and that
was bad wait he's just thrown
off the trail he was in much ado about
nothing as the villain and he's very bad
in it but now that I'm thinking about it
that could have been a red herring but
he's also as he was a villain no
Shakespeare but he never does an accent
though a man who's been around for a
thousand years that's a great way
accents he has to protect no matter what
role he plays he talks like a dude from
Southern California yes that's so smart
I think that's safe yeah so just to go
back to shapes and my theory that he is
actually Hamlet um in modern Keanu's
lifetime he filmed speed which was a
breakout hits that one with the bus that
wouldn't turn off with a Sandra Bullock
oh yeah he turned down eleven million
dollars for speed too instead to play
the lead in a production of Hamlet at a
humble Canadian Theatre in Manitoba
weird right but you do is terrible play
character he would play sequels John
wick matrix come on Bill and Ted to none
of those are bad all right well what I'm
saying is the man is not opposed to
sequels so he turns down speed to four
he turns out eleven million dollars for
speed to to do the Shakespeare play of
Hamlet and this review from Roger Lewis
in The Sunday Times said he quite
embodied the innocence the splendid fury
the animal grace of the leaps and bounds
and what leap Simba okay the animal
grace of the leaps and bounds emotional
violence that formed the Prince of
Denmark he is one of the top three
Hamlet's I have ever seen for a simple
reason
he is Hamlet Richard Lewis knew Roger
Lewis knew voted Richard all the Louis's
new is there footage of him because no
there's no footage and isn't that weird
- no it's a Manitoban production
yeah it's not weird they didn't have a
green screen but was using an accent
because he's still key on it like you've
dad the conceit of being Keanu right
yeah
also generally in Shakespeare I mean I
don't know I've seen a lot of
Shakespeare plays they normally don't
really put them on I mean really well
yeah unless you're like see British
actors I think the modern concept now is
to not necessarily have to do an accent
because it wouldn't have done anything
like a British accent anyway because
it's not cool yeah I think Finnish
accents from that time sounded like
garbled trash yeah he is Hamlet yes well
and he can't shuffle off that mortal
coil oh no must be a hamlet reference no
I
wherefrom Buies Creek all right it's
just the Lion King link that's the plot
of Hamlet I played a manservant in one
production in college what I don't think
that's in the one that she's the man is
based off of that's a different play no
well no matter what the plate
you should never be relegated to just be
a man man sir
I thought you were saying in Hamlet you
played I was just shouting out
Shakespeare in general okay what else so
um I had teased earlier about how he may
have hired help with from makeup artists
to to help age him perhaps there is a
photo of Paul Mooney the French actor
looking older but it looks weird it kind
of looks like if you put your face
through an app to look older like oh
well they had those been me in the 19th
century they did but they did have
makeup brushes and other makeup things
but do we have like historic pictures
where it's like oh that's Keanu you know
I see those floating around the internet
it's like like a group of a group photo
of like miners and like rules somewhere
on earth
yeah these are American miners or miners
both pianos is one of them Keanu is
immortal calm tracks all of these photos
but these are the ones that have like
there's there's information about the
men in the photos that can connect them
to Keanu I wouldn't want to come to you
with just a picture you know I've got
everything to back it up he has like
okay also no one found Paul manase body
are you saying that once he becomes who
he's going to become in a particular
generation he has to kind of live a life
and then die that's fulfilling like
that's the only way I would want to be
immortal well maybe those the only ones
we've seen I mean you're talking about
him having like eight hundred year gaps
in between these we don't know what he
was doing in there maybe maybe he wasn't
always in the public eye he was being a
minor that's what I'm saying every once
in a while he decides okay
this lifetime I'm gonna be in the public
eye or you know you try something out
for three years you hate it maybe you
disappear for a little roam around
company started out as a doctor and like
he was pretty good at it and then he
decided to quit and do acting and that's
what he really likes and Keanu is an
actor is there something you're holding
back um is there like a big clincher yes
I do have like an empty tomb well he's
not no he's not dead you know I mean we
did cover an empty tomb so if that's
your that was one of my first points but
I could say it again no he was there in
2003
Keanu actually made waves when he gifted
fifty million dollars of his matric
earnings to the unsung heroes of the
production the costume and special
effects team what fifty million dollars
to the costume and special effects from
major a fifty million dollars off of the
matrix
yeah and more so he must have made a lot
more than that he's worth fifty million
of his matrix money to the costume
department yes when asked about it he
said and I quote money is the last thing
I think about I could live on what I
have already made for the next few
centuries
sounds like the way
and an old Holy Roman Emperor would talk
with one with tons of gold in their
attic for when they need it while
they're immortal well let me just say
that I'm looking at Keanu Reeves as a
kid and all you see his pictures of him
like since like the Bill and Ted era yes
and then like maybe babies which was
about traveling through time there's why
was he so good at it why was it so
successful because he's done it yeah
there's does it at the speed of time so
there's this one there's this one
picture that they're using and it says
so it turns out Keanu Reeves is immortal
WTF yeah that's right okay here's one
more that's definitely him this is a any
okay that looks like Riley Blevins who I
went to middle school with his nose is
wrong it's different no nose is wrong
you do expect to see more of a scent
nose yes there's the oh that's the only
piece of evidence that we got it's um a
anything sister who doesn't look like
him at all
a sister well here's my question why did
he give 50 million dollars to a costume
group specifically I'm I'm astounded by
it that is the biggest piece of evidence
he wore a black trench coat the whole
time my theory is that what he was
frustrated he wanted something more I
just want to say the Keano is immortal
theory is gaining a lot of traction in
the past five years and I think it will
continue to do so as Keanu gets older
but doesn't age weird so I think he did
that to get in really good with some
trusted makeup and special effects
workers like I bet he made friends with
a special effects person on that set and
they were like okay I'll do this for you
in 40 years if you like give me to my
appreciation dollars not me like I I
think that's a good special effects
worker if he's trying to get in good
with the whole special effects team
wouldn't you just die though isn't that
the easy just die just die and go away
for a little bit well I think he likes
living his life he did so much work to
become the Keanu Reaves we know now it's
a lot tougher to die now than it used to
be that's true
it's getting think about it yeah yeah
dying because there's cold there's
corners and there's there's people who
certify the death stop being a doctor
because there would be too many
questions he would have too many doctor
friends you will this this theory will
be vindicated in one point in the future
Cano Reeves is killed in some sort of
accident where they can't really into
motorcycles they got it yeah knock on
wood I really don't want Keanu Reeves
today I love him so I just I I knocked
on what to loud and this is an audio
recording but that's how much I and
that's why that's that's why you want to
believe this because you want him to be
immortal yeah I mean we believe what we
want to believe
I don't want it so bad that I would be
clouded by a lack of facts and I have so
many facts well so many facts like why
light though we're like if if he if like
we happen to meet or something and fall
in love which could happen do you take
me with him no that's right you're a
yeah why do you think Hamlet is so sad
he's not a vampire
but I just want to close this out next
to a picture of Keanu throwing a
baseball there he's holding like a
scepter and a ball thing and I just
wanted to compare it similarly you
should have broken that one out well
they're both left-handed and I want to
say recently
kyani was interviewed in depth by
Esquire as promotion for his upcoming
film John wick which is excellent John
wick - actually it's good and dirty do I
have to see the first one before i watch
the second you don't have to but you
should because the first one is really
perfect it's like one of my favorite
movies and I get really scared and like
super intense actually a lot of people
died in that I heard super can't even
die in a movie so fun it's just great
weight has Keanu ever die
the movie great question I don't know he
must have has he he didn't die in Point
Break he didn't die in Devils of again
he's definitely if he did what would
that prove yeah I mean does he die at
the end he's an actually doesn't know
how to die oh that's the one thing he
does ever takes anyway so he was
interviewed and it was brought up this
online conspiracy which is online
conspiracy that's like gaining in
popularity and he responds extremely
convincingly with Oh what really and
when the interview shows him these
pictures of his former identities he
goes that's crazy oh my gosh
which is how you respond exactly if
someone if you had to cover up something
that you know you were lying about why
don't you with that because that's what
you're doing right now is what I think
about when I think of Keanu Reeves
acting pretty much it so I agree he's
acting and he has died he died he
committed suicide in the devil yeah he
comes back he comes back and then of
course he dies in the matrix but he
comes back yes but in the watcher and
Ted he dies and comes back right but in
the watcher he was burned to death
inside of a warehouse actually what
vampires always did when they were
pretending to die yeah like in toilet
and it had lake house have you seen the
watcher - when he comes back while
crossing the street but resurrects after
receiving a warning Oh guys he does not
die in movies well he died in the watch
joking gun to me that sounds like that
Clint yeah there's no maybe he's telling
a story through all his movies if you
thought about that a lot of movies he's
leaving a trail of bread all time I mean
all time literally that is all of the
time well Keano if you ever want to come
on your biscuits and uh please either
reinforce or confirm or deny this
particular theory we'll have you on and
we'll have let you guys back yes I would
behave ourselves I would panic and die
she might cry but it'll be fine
she cried five minutes into homeward
bound
I'd like to point out which beautiful do
you guys recently watch that together
yes we did oh wow what's that is that an
animal movie animals talking to dogs
Annette getting home
it's like Sally Field and Michael J Fox
looks like my dog yes too much chance
the rappers in it
you got any conspiracies about homeward
bound yeah they used a bunch of
different cats cuz when we were watching
[Laughter]
standard practice for animals yeah they
use multiple cat but their budget might
not have been great because one of them
is like wicked cross-eyed and they cut
to it and this cat is just look in one
direction looking at your nose cat my
conspiracy is that all the animals that
used to film homeward bound are still
alive because I just wanted to be true
what a nightmare making that movie yeah
that's what we kept saying the whole
time I was like the production nightmare
of this anyway Keanu Reeves see John
wick - he's immortal and he also here's
one last quote he was interviewed by his
motorcycle hobby which you know and he
was asked if his immortality factored
into his riding style of motorcycles and
he answers well you know it does
actually
so we confirmed it himself I don't
understand what do you mean he was
interviewed by his motorcycle about his
motorcycle hobby oh by a square a-square
okay and they and they threw the
immortal theory at him just like they
showed him the immortal thing and then
later they asked him about his he's like
well actually a judge that is the way to
play it don't deny it just embrace it
cool it is funny how seems now that in
all of his interviews now they're asking
about his immortality which is kind of
funny yeah I bet that gets old forever
he must be pretty used to it mm-hmm okay
this has been intriguing doesn't
thinking I'm gonna be thinking about
this every time I see
a movie and think about Kelsey Lohan to
let me forget that died and well in
Lindsey every time I see her it didn't I
don't see her anymore movie she who
never existed rest in peace she existed
well guys thanks for coming in and there
you have it we are conspiracy theory up
thanks to Lizzie and Ellie and when that
conversation wrapped up I just got back
from from darting to the restroom
darling I did not yeah that's not what I
call it i guarded so I didn't shart it
was one of the other and I didn't get to
tell them goodbye it's okay I did we
stop I took care of I mean I'll see him
okay because they work yes an
interesting point that Lizzie Lizzie
made as she was exiting she pulled up
the the 17 article that she had read in
this there is a 17 article that
definitively says that the girl who
played the twin or the girl played the
stand-in is seven years older than
Lindsay Lohan and she thinks that the
Wikipedia entry has been edited because
it's so easy to edit wiki so the
conspiracy deepens I mean so at some
point at one point Seventeen magazine
was was was part of this because they
they thought actually got a loss because
I didn't understand why her being seven
years old of mattered because she's just
a stand-in because that would mean that
the stand-in photos were doctored
because they look a girl is seven years
older than her in real life the neck
photos photos he never exist instead it
was actually her twin I'll see who was
in those photos originally and there was
taken out if I would have understood
that at the time instead of thinking
about my bowels in that moment I got
lost I could tell you were distracted
then I would have been well uh yeah what
can I do then I would have been
convinced so okay what a late than never
it's that easy I hope you're convinced
to continue to ear biscuit with us let
us know what you think using hash tag
ear biscuits everywhere hash tags are
found leaving a comment on YouTube a
review on iTunes
or anywhere else that you're able to
comment it's all helpful you know how
much stuff for us continue to share the
biscuits with friends loved ones enemies
same what to your your ex I would kill
your biscuit to your ex just kill for a
real biscuit right now that's the worst
thing you could do right now is think
about food and talk about food peanut
butter on a bisque pretend that it
doesn't bake and gonna biscuit you know
they were so unhealthy take cinnamon
rolls cut them in half and put scrambled
eggs and sausage inside that's what I'll
do sometimes man that's what you'll do
tomorrow oh we're gonna get done with
your episode but this episode is over it
is in it yeah
[Music]